this might be bold but i'm gonna have to
remove a sin before we even start
this dog here fishing for a t-shirt that
says compliments only is a great visual
gag
look man game respects game however as
the sin lords death giveth they equally
doth taketh away there's absolutely no
need to censor the word patty here
okay show when you say you love merch
and you flaunt a shirt you sell it
we have a new prometheus shirt we showed
off in a video recently it's also
available in our store
whereas i scrolled through five pages of
shirts to only discover that this shirt
isn't even available
you know though now that i really think
about it they really did spare me a lot
of horrible looks at the sunday buffet
rush
my acid rain will destroy all things
green and natural
but not the very natural skin of the
diesel weasel or its very natural body
parts in general those are immune
for reasons there's only one solution
for earth's pollution
planet tina looks straight to camera as
if she has a polar icecap's chance in
hell of changing the lifestyle habits of
an audience which is currently juggling
their freehand from a reddit scroll an
energy drink in their own personal
yosemite shirt
what the [ __ ] was that kidnapping also
that was an obvious rip-off of captain
planet and by your powers combined i
will
not have our childhood hero mocked go
planeteers
mother nature has enlisted the help of
four young adults from each major
ethnicity
that's actually not racist but the way
the show pokes fun of it might be
great taylor murphy dumps me the day
before his hella big pool party and my
little brother is dating a phase four
superhero um
actually summer i think you'll find that
playing athena can't even be in phase
four because she isn't even
in the mcu cannon i mean she doesn't
even appear
[Music]
just shoot me in the [ __ ] head until
i die a comment that is very triggering
while simultaneously meaningless
after that bullsh decoy episode what in
the name of sweet baby measures is going
on with jerry's breakfast how does he
expect to eat this soft boiled egg if
his toast isn't pre-cut into strips
ready for dipping he can't afford to cut
the toast now every second he wastes the
gooey egg interior is slowly solidifying
also the egg wasn't even cooked and why
didn't he rescue the toast
why is breakfast three planets are all
ending in a delayed succession surely
there must be a multitude of cataclysmic
events be following a plethora of
planets across the universe
if rick really wanted to go on a doomed
planet bar crawl isn't his ship fast
enough to prevent their proximity to
each other from being the limiting
factor
or failing this couldn't he use his oh i
don't know
portal gun if you don't want to help me
i'll find my own goddamn way to the
wildfire
kids tina girl have you gained weight
well i had a plant-based doughnut
yesterday
just a half sugar is worst thing for
figure darling
i don't know what's worse about this
exchange the fact that tina is being
fat-shamed for eating a
doughnut or that said donut was
plant-based i'm gonna send both
just to be safe this is freaking you out
huh no what's freaking me out is
this phone fitting into that pocket so
are you two dating
asking this question to a kid
bonding with your grandparent over and i
can't believe i'm going to say this
don't look now but someone's giving you
the big eye what
in a sea of aliens with big eyes all
staring at them on the party float you
don't say ready right meet me at the car
calling a ship a car
one of these has to be hers where'd she
go where'd the purses come from
they left away seconds ago and returned
with 50 bags were they having sex next
to the lost and found room
also why would a race of aliens bring
their purses to an end of the world orgy
and then abandon them at the bar
money would be meaningless
identification pointless and whatever
other products you keep in your bag you
kind of want to have them on your person
right
also also many of these purses are
shoulder length and i think their
sensitive elbow orifices would rub up on
the bag and either overstimulate or
chafe or both
[ __ ] me why does this show make me think
of these things how do you let someone
permanently tattoo the wrong arrow
directions on your body i mean you're
literally wearing the reference on your
chest so you
know better idiot step idiots
isn't it interesting how they can summon
planet tina and whatever she is holding
but can also force her to be dismissed
without the item she holds
this spell was obviously crafted by the
dark lord that rules plots in the world
of convenience
this really must be the greatest party
in the universe this guy's loving it so
much he duplicated himself so he can
enjoy it from 12 different perspectives
neat he goes honey calling a woman honey
actually calling anyone honey you don't
even know me kristin from denny's
oh that's how you smoke marijuana i mean
i of course knew that because i smoked
the reefer all the time
wow how about this weather sure is
unseasonably warm
tonight what is this mop made of that
would allow it to break a storage shelf
and obliterate a container
what are morty's teeth made of that
would allow him to instantly bite off a
finger
what are his lips made of that he could
blast a fireball out of his mouth
without any singeing
we've seen enough of these now that i
really shouldn't be surprised by how
quickly and remorselessly morty turns to
murder
and yet his phone keep going to
voicemail his phone has been ringing for
a minute and 43 seconds
before going to voicemail what sort of
hell hole are they living in
they should be relieved by their
impending deaths also voicemail
which one of you ordered a pizza no one
ordered pizza what is this
not ordering pizza is always a sin morty
shows up in a
murder pie hat and my question is did he
swipe a hat from a local pizzeria with
that name or did he
stop at a hat embroidery store and have
this whipped up for just such an
occasion
imagine either being so dumb or having
so little regard for human life
that you repeatedly machine gun your
boss just because your intended target
ran behind her
i've never had a magical ring streaming
air forced into my mouth before but
let's say i had i truly believe my
instinct would be to keep my mouth
open rather than create an unimaginably
tight seal around said ring
i'm not a fan of gratuitous murder but
this right here gets my
seal of approval sorry i've been
harboring that one for a while
okay i'll stop now
small consolation but this soon to be
dead slart of arson would be great at tv
sins
not keeping your eyes on the road while
driving through what appears to be an
asteroid field
that's right girlfriend this is what
you're up against
elbow hemorrhoids olecranon prolapse
best set up elbow titties on
more gluts okay hitting your funny bone
under any circumstances
is agony but i can't begin to imagine
how painful it would be to accidentally
catch these
l boobies on say the corner of a table
you know what i have someone i could
check with
aidan a yes how much would that hurt
it would suck yeah that sounds right
thanks
you're welcome weirdos then i put my
sunglasses on and walked out like
nothing happened what a romantic story
about our son killing a room full of
people
i don't care if they were technically in
self-defense morty just admitted to
multiple murders while
casually playing whatever the fork this
board game is and no one cares
and no jerry and beth that quip in those
mildly withering stairs do not count as
disapproval
i only want to spend as much time as
possible with your son my son
is 14 miss i'm really glad that someone
is finally addressing the underaged
elephant in the room
but why is beth a the only person to
realize that this is sick and wrong
and b more outraged by this than all of
the recently described
boner-induced bloodlust there's only one
solution
whatever that solution is i'm fairly
certain it lays somewhere on the
spectrum after rhyming couplets but
way before multiple homicides
morty is crushed and runs away because
planeteena's current body count is 25
higher than his competitive
relationships like this are so toxic
this gay sex with my dad is terrific
paternal sodomy patotomy so der you know
what there's just some places i will not
dip my portmanteaus in
now you're grossed out summer this is
what's pushed you over the line
not the incest not the l boobs not
whatever the [ __ ]
this was swimming through these bodies
and kicking this gropy tentacle is what
really took the biscuit for you
this works so why the [ __ ] wasn't it
plan a is genocide really a palatable
price to pay for the sake of rick's
party boner
well let me just grab my phone here um
although both can be cloaca bearing this
crew drawing is clearly a frog
which is an amphibian not a reptile
cap should have antenna caps no cap
i'm in danger storming your castle on my
steve milady
[Music]
stop talking like that i can't
understand you everybody look at the
moon
everybody's seeing the moon the moon is
[Music]
[Applause]
this gay sex with my dad is terrific the
lion must be drawn here
this far no further how are you doing
that with your mouth
collect the whole set last chance to pee
on me
if i had to i'd pee on any one of you